okay so I got like a bone to pick with
this episode this is the episode the
Great Divide and I'll give you the
rundown real fast I mean most do you
know it but I you got this this Canyon
called the Great Divide obviously you
suppose can't be like the Grand Canyon
and these two different types of people
they want to cross the canyon they've
been warring and feuding with each other
for years but they both want to escape
the fire nation well there's only one
guy this earthbender who can get them
through the canyon and he agrees to take
them both through and of course if three
heroes are with them and they're going
through and the earthbender he gets
injured because he says don't bring food
with you and each of the sides assume
the other side would bring food that
makes it okay for them to bring food and
the reason for this was because of this
this feud or this prejudice that had
been long long ago between these two
people um and there's a misunderstanding
and you don't know which side is true
and it's obvious it's an obvious episode
but the same time they're they're sorta
having fun with it they start playing
with it like this you know kind of
clever fable where uh Aang says that you
know I'm the great peacekeeper instead I
can find the middle with anything and
he's having trouble with these two
groups of people they were just not
listening to reason
so he decides he'll separate them heaven
go these two separate ways and sends um
Katara and Sokka Sokka to go and find
out why they're feuding and they both
get different sides of the story and
they get sucked into the side that's
really clever and I like that a lot um
and when it when it comes back to where
they meet up they all starting including
the brother and sister and they start
getting this great big battle with each
other I mean where there's a let's fight
to the death and then more of these
giant spider creatures you should see
the spies it's like a mix between a
spider and a pterodactyl I love them um
but they come in and of course they
figure out they have to work together in
order to defeat them and then very
clever kid show way of doing it but very
inventive uh the way they defeat them
climb up the canyon everything so you
to be okay up but they're still feuding
so that Hank tells them he says you know
okay this is way way met this is about
these two feuding people 100 years ago
and they go yeah he says I knew those
people that they were kids they were
like little kids yeah and turns out the
story is actually a very romanticized
exaggerated version of these two kids
playing a ball game and that's it
and that this whole battle and this
prejudice and everything was just over
these two kids feuding with each other
the whole time I mean we're talking like
toddlers or something like that and they
decided as incredibly stupid reason to
fight let's not fight anymore
now if the episode ended there you would
have had a really clever episode it
really dived into sort of prejudice and
how stupid it can make you and how
pointless it is half the time and how
much it makes things worse and on top of
it it doesn't just say hey people who
are prejudiced are bad they're just born
that way
that's it it looks at from a different
point of view of how did this get
started and how it can get twisted how
other people can get sucked into it and
you know how something so miniscule can
turn to something so large if you wet it
and so you had a really good story
literally the last like half a minute
like fucks it all up in my opinion it
just totally fucks it up egg looks at
the two kids the brother and sister and
they're well yeah how'd you know that
story I read it did you really come
across them at night just like nope I
was like T Kiki off we go
bullshit that is bullshit okay so you're
making this great big message about
about feuding and Prejudice and then by
saying it's a lie this didn't happen
you're pretty much saying that lying to
fix prejudice is okay or that and here's
the thing with lying I'm not gay act
like there's never a time to liar that
we're not gonna need to lie I you know I
try not to go extreme on stuff there's
always gonna be exceptions to the rule
there's gonna be times where you're
gonna need to lie is gonna be times
you're gonna need to
truth and so on so forth but for me
lying should only be done if you're not
clever enough to find a way to tell the
truth properly you know if you can't
find a clever way to deliver this news
um and so or if you're not clever enough
to find the answer to the problem
so if egg fell he had to lie that's a
stretch but I I could buy it a little
bit more if he wasn't happy about it
it's like well this was the only choice
I had and I feel really bad about her
what does this say about me as a monk
you know the peacekeeping monk instead I
had to actually make something up and no
it's just a funny love tee-hee-hee off
we go it it really after I saw it I mean
I saw in the shower I'm like did that
make scented that really no there's no
way I can justify this that was fucking
stupid because you could just cut half
met earlier and had this really great
clever even funny story but instead by
having him say he lied and having no
remorse for it it's pretty much saying
that all the other prejudices in the
world they can just be solved by making
something up you know and that's that's
not cool you know as people we don't
want to grow that way we want to learn
it what's wrong with ourselves and fix
it and look inward and all that stuff
and instead not just just make it up you
know all the racial stuff that happened
the past labor in seven days alien it's
fun aliens came down brainwash the white
guys and uh yeah that's why we're jerks
that's it fuck that shit
just know I actually it's like I got
angry at this episode because it was it
had sort of these peaks and valleys like
oh is it gonna be just this oh that's a
new twist
oh man are we really doing that oh well
that's sort of a new look at and and it
was turning out really really clever and
I was actually even thinking they're
going to take the route where you don't
really know what happened in the
backstory which in a sense is still the
route they took you don't know which is
the true side but if you're gonna do
that you just have them come to
an agreement not knowing which side is
the correct side and just saying hey
this doesn't affect us anymore in many
respects it may be never really affected
us let's look at what's really important
but instead he has to make stuff up he
has to create a Santa Claus
it's like that's what it's like it's
like saying there's a Santa Claus no
there isn't
oh wait there is again it's it's oh man
did that not work for me um and you know
like mostly episodes everything else was
pretty good you know the comedy was
pretty good and the creations you know
this this grand this Great Divide the
valley uh you know but look or the
canyon looked really cool but oh man
this is like the first episode I mean
they Spielberg did it's like it was fine
until like the last until the ending is
just like and I hate thinking that way I
don't like you know glancing over
everything else because the ending
wasn't good but this is literally
everything that's been building up to
and it did have an ending it had a good
ending in a smart ending and then they
added that on top of it it just wasn't
needed uh and I was trying to get around
like some sort of philosophical way that
this ending can be justified and I just
can't do it
I just cannot justify that ending
especially for kids especially when you
had two or three perfectly good other
endings I mean you could have ended this
even a couple endings earlier but but I
like the Radley when we rang tells the
story about the two little kids because
I thought that was very funny and that
was a very good way of really hammering
in what the message is but then no yeah
you know if you come across you know a
Klansman a black panther uh just make up
make up a story you know say um a lion
from Narnia came is just like you know
hey dude uh I just made you black and
white because I thought the colors were
cool but no you hey teacher and that's
Bab no really Aslan said that to me and
they'd be like oh okay okay that story
makes no sense but it doesn't matter
neither does this it just makes no sense
so I
Oh God I don't know man that that ending
pissed me off because the rest the
episode was good it was a legitimately
good episode you know I get it doesn't
seem like it further too much uh you
know the Wonder thing I'll bring up
outside of that Gibby
you know my opinion everything else in
the episode a lot of the thing else are
asked about is that after at the
beginning of the series they say they're
gonna go to the North Pole that's
ultimately where they want to go uh and
anxious but we have to drop by these
three or four places here why oh because
I wanna go penguin sledding here I want
to see this great site I want to see
this and teehee ha we have the time
we're just gonna learn you know the
North Pole and hey again it'll outwit
the firebenders looking for us so you
know and he's a little kid there
although kids okay now there's like a
really distinct mission like holy shit
we gotta do this fast because there's a
comet coming and yet they're still going
to like the Great Divide and stuff is
that were they getting something there
are they really still just making these
pit stops to look at you know to go
sightseeing it is that really what's
going on unless again unless I'm missing
something but that there's a comet man
and the violations can take if it gonna
they're gonna blow your shit and you see
in the Grand Canyon no making up stories
no you don't do this man you don't
you're you're a monk it's supposed to
know better than this so that was my
thought at the Recio so died thought was
fine if I worked out really well just
that last 30 seconds I'm always
fascinated how any uh uh you know
anything that has a story can I'm
fascinated by how it can destroy itself
in in such small amount of times um I'm
seeing quite a lot of that recently and
and it is fascinating it just shows I
guess in some ways just how fragile a
story is or how easily it can be
destroyed with just the right tinkering
but it had to come from a really good
spot first you had to be infested to
begin with and I was the rest of the
episode is really good
um I if anyone else can see how this can
be justified I mean talk about it or
just guys that I don't know cuz I just
could not find a way uh not being
against lying there's always going to be
times to lie I did not see why he had to
make up a story here that that makes him
look like a strong character or makes
him look like he was in the right you
know if it turns out he had to do this
and they acknowledge he was in the wrong
I can understand a little bit more cuz I
could be about human failure and how
sometimes we can't always find the right
answers and you know that's tough but
that's life but no they're making it
look like he was in the right and a
funny little thing and that II that's
prejudice man that's like the big holy
shit wars and death and slavery and all
this terrible stuff stuff is still going
on now and you just sort of down at the
end of the answer is just make it up no
hmm all right so that's that's my little
rant amad episode um sorry sir wait they
get angry about but I just ah I couldn't
justify it so uh there and maybe you
could uh I love to know how if you can
justify it how you how you see it adds
up but I I good man I just couldn't
couldn't see how it could work so um
maybe there's my prejudice I'm like I
don't know so uh yeah that's about it
sorry I couldn't like the ending more
but yeah that's my two cents on it um
other than that great episode and as
always I look forward to seeing the next
one see you there